bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo su che cosa
potrebbe mai essere un uomo con una effe
sul tetto sarà mica super fa vj e invece
no perché ecco io man to man who fell
made man who fell e bellissimi
complimenti al naso di film e ragazzi è
solo quello vale il gioco comunque
ragazzi prima si chiama fail man perché
è il supereroe dei file e diretti contro
il face quest ragazzi una roba del
genere solo che ascolta visione non so
perché il tuo cappello a due tette però
cos'è
non ho niente soldi questo sembra troppo
un lavoro per fair il man che non so
dove sia finito come faccio io
intervenire essendo come tra il face
questa è una roba duplicati
ok sono riuscito adesso geniale perfetto
è il mero risolve tutto amico mio hai
quei soldi poi ti arrestrati esatto fa
chi è ha baciato della bambina che sai
cos'è a gonfiare un palloncino perfetto
la ecco arriva faceman di gonfia il
palloncino del giro dai vola sicuro 200
per cento con patate lo sapevo ma ci
avrei scommesso la vita un vero super
mija spider man supera non servono un
caso non c'è faceman chi è questa tizia
bellissimo deve attraversare la strada
si vuole fail man che cosa fa anche se
insozzata tutta bruttissimo giuro che
non vuole non l'ho fatto apposta per
aria arriva fail man che risolve sicuro
che hai visto un alieno zio rock e
facendoli cano spiegate spingendo una
macchina laimer data ancora di più
fantastico film con complimenti io gli
avrei dato un naso giusto già che c'era
su pizarro uguale proprio identico e lui
ai miei capelli stati uguale fammi
capire a joystiq nodo vincere io
risolto non avevo mai pensato di fare
così nella mia vita e ho giocato a te
che dovevo svegliarmi prima notte siamo
ragazzi c'era del fuoco e devo spegnere
il fuoco bravo famer vuoi avere un naso
abnorme quello che vuoi ma gesù santa fe
i tacchi fail merita chi no lasciamo
perdere sarà un idrante milan c'è della
band della benzina
ovvio ci andiamo perfetto
hai salvato la vita al mondo credimi
perfetto giorno i dentisti voi no dal
duce film arriva la botta ancora di
famiglia che botta l'ultimo regalo che è
successo ha detto è un uomo questo era
la festa di halloween primi erano tutti
esseri umani ok pazienza bravo film ci
hai provato almeno va bene dice che sta
morendo di 72 riportarli dell'acqua
perfetto come faccio a portargliela
acciona tipo chi cazzo è questa notizia
a noi fa il bene frame nell'ascolto zio
e li porti della stai facendo stai
pregando riportarli nella quali serve
dell'acqua o beve pp come bear grylls
uno dei due il palo stai facendo ho
trovato dell'acqua sott'acqua a quelle
petrolio credo è infatti e trova il guar
dall'alto positivo vi come almeno sei
ricco credo mi sta facendo sempre più se
devo dire la verità è bellissimo che
cos'è questo non prende un segnale
arriva faymann come faccio a far
riprendere segnalano la batteria
batteria a carico perfetto sei pronto
zio carica alice presente con le cover
dei telefoni che ricaricano il telefono
non servono un cazzo questa la
tecnologia ha posto a posto telefono si
è carico possa essere messo poco a stai
scassinando una banca valutò già pensato
io nel primo livello si va verso una
mano ti do ti do una mano la crepa una
tre sono uscito dalla banca e io ero
dentro la baracca giusto sono qui lo zio
ci penso io è stato risolto non risolto
era un film era un film devo prendere il
gatto che pianto cia sta tizia una
motosega una motosega sì non voglio
sapere che cosa serve una motosega però
prendiamo il gatto e il maine
ecco prendi la motosega che sei bravo a
tagliare ecco non è che puoi andare a
prenderla il gatto e portarlo a tagliamo
l'albero giusto
ok a posto la vecchietta è morta papara
vecchia salite nella che abbia mai visto
lo voglio campagne per gli sposi
sticazzi debba complimenti per la donna
vi cominati statua a sta cosa no così ti
fai seghini non sa più niente che devo
fare qui ha poi come faccio a farle
dotto che alle tette
speravo di sì ma non è così io spero che
il tuo bene sia più grande del tuo naso
me faccia prima bottiglia voti carli sul
bene che non ha a ciel s c'è una f sulla
camicia ovvio volta faceman fa in file
come si deve ecco perfetto non mira gli
add on sale vabbè tanto rimbalzerà il
proiettile sicuro si può non l'ho
beccata nell'occhio e beh pazienza se
beccava più in basso rimbalzava solvit
un occhio nero credimi andiamo avanti
comunque ma fatta finiti la bambola nel
lago me lo devi spiegare primo ok
devo capire ancora fammi capire il
perche ti prego sono i care ragazzi
piangiamo tutti forte forte che che si
risolve a non succhiare la l'acqua del
lago dono messa in quale vescica di
preciso va bene è la bambola c'è
dell'amata prenda eccola qui perfetto ci
si contento e che file è questo non ai
pesci va bene ma che cazzo ne frega dei
pesci
vabbè non è un problema per i pesci le
papere no
pazienza
devi fermare la macchina a star da è
perfetto picchia che potenza farmi
cliccare mio dio salvando due papere ma
in complesso sto sfasciando tutte le
auto fantastico anche riguardo a dico
non è arrivata bilancio quattro morti
per incidente però almeno le pappe le
papere sono salve non potete dire niente
premo la inter non è inter unter premio
f dal primo set cerchiamo in due è che
cerchiamo è quello il tuo indirizzo la
chioccia del tuo indirizzo quello non lo
salvo è una roba amico mio cei dei
capelli che ti invidio credimi che
carini che le faccia china continuano a
baciarsi e tu continui a dio che tolga i
ragazzi queste stalking a livelli
estremi vi si avvicinano si baciano
pervertito se lo facessero che cosa
faresti giusto per non lo voglio sapere
guardano bene che faccio mi spingo io li
spingo vicario li ho fatti decollare
nello spazio perfetto
questo è l'inizio di alin isole shaun
praticamente fantastico mazzo di rose in
mano sta continuando a farsi le pippe
all'aria entrò nel negozio apre un
negozio il cazzo io vado nel negozio
sono fashion caffè già che portava i
tacchi non andava tanto bene anche le
calze da asciugare basta è arrivata
adesso si innamora di me perché ha visto
ecco però che è successo non ho capito
questa va bene poche domande ragazzi in
questi giochi poche domande quando
avanti l'autobus bastardi e vabbè
successo anche a me tante volte che la
faccio ha perso perso così perfetto
dovevo arrivare in fretta come faccio ad
arrivare prendi l'autobus fai qualcosa
cosa può fare
chiedevo questo cliccato clicchiamo mio
zio è sono finito nella parte brutta di
internet
un'altra volta c'è una f da qualche
parte che non vedo
non so se c'è una ecco io amo ok adesso
sei appoggiare adesso l'autobus mo
finalmente andare a destinazione guarda
come contento perfetto justin bieber
perfetta e lui justin bieber e lo stanno
picchiando ma arriva faceman che ecco
picchia i picchiatori che ho salvato la
vita a justin bieber ti alzi hanno
picchiato anch'io eh vabbè abbiamo
picchiato tutti i ragazzi meglio così
perché giasson vivermi sembri kimi
turner prova per i ragazzi 19 siamo e
per ultimo possono fare gli stop non
possa nessuno ma passerà fail membri
ragazzi vi sto per schiacciare l'auto
mentre lui non guarda bene lì sicuro
aggiustata adesso ben cercava benzina
almeno funziona almeno quello ragazzi
posso volerla tutta la vita anch'io
quest'auto è bellissima l'ultimo livello
in assoluto e poi ho finito eclissi deve
impedire l'eclissi maledizione
sceglierebbe non lamentarti fa qualcosa
che devo fare
c'è un eclissi ma perché devo premere
morti tutti che c'è stata una crisi che
devo fare film e salva il mondo cazzo
fai qualcosa cosa che faccio che
cellophane quest'uomo è bello ora fai
vai sulla luna niente c'è verso
cos'è questo cliccato su un razzo vai
vai coraggio ma vai veloce salva il
mondo perfetto ma lui popolare non c'è
bisogno del razzo invece sì perché ha
distrutto la luna si è salvato il mondo
no no è andato tutto a [ __ ] e
pazienza complimenti per questa
avventura fantastica finisce qui
fenomeno resta testo bellissima partita
ma io li farei un applauso solo per il
naso perché bellissimo cioè io sono
innamorato di quello però amico mio
ti prego non i tacchi comunque ragazzi
conclude vito spero che vi sia piaciuto
come site ragazzi del video è piaciuto
lasciando momento mi piace anche a
faccia di facebook e con il video
tansizione sa se avresti discreti civino
prossimo ad un prossimo file con il naso
che piccolo belle ragazze